Mr chair should we be using our micro
microphones for purposes of recording
well now it is oh now we're here oh I'll
okay
for the public then we just it yelled uh
House Bill 272 because it was in the
budget House Bill 332 relative to school
building aid for projects
uh was in hb1
is there any other idea
okay uh HP 419
relative to mass learning communities
program for the college
community college system making a
program therefore
Joe moved to itl do we have a second
Mary okay
all those in favor of ytl
okay
uh House Bill 420 relatively
availability of funding for the Dual and
concurrent enrollment program for the
community college system making an
appropriation therefore was in hb2
Joe moves itl Mary seconds all those in
favor of itl
okay
House Bill 468 making an appropriation
of the Department of Education for an
attorney to recodify education laws
oh boy
I think this had the the bill itself had
a thousand dollars or some
ridiculously a known number in it and I
don't
uh can you
I read a comment from the Senate that it
was not supported that much by the by
the department but we got somebody here
to let us know
if you'd like to come forward into the
microphone
good afternoon Diana Fenton with the
Department of Education
um I'm happy to speak to the bill let me
just give me a minute to pull it up or
I does it have the support of the
it came from the Department so there is
a recognition that there are a lot of
laws in the education book that
sometimes are contrary to each other are
duplicative
um there is an enormous amount of
information in that law book and
um
it would be a benefit to the education
community and the field that we serve to
hire someone to go through and really
cull through that information it is a
tedious process it's well worth it but
it's a an undertaking the department
does not have the resources to do
I do believe that it would be a benefit
to everyone in the legislature
especially in House Education and to the
field and I appreciate representative
Heath support
um from her chair over there I think
thank you Mr chair just a question I
remember when we talked about this bill
the first time the agreement was that
the estimate was extremely rough and
really was nowhere near the actual
amount needed to come to complete this
can you update us on any uh refinements
or additions to that estimate how long
would this take how expensive would it
be I mean it's been a few months since
then
so I just pulled up the bill here and uh
it allows for a hundred thousand dollar
appropriation
um
and I
that is an enormous amount of money and
I'm not here to tell you otherwise but I
can tell you that given the task I think
it's appropriate I think what you will
find and I don't mean you individually
but the generic uh General you is once
we find an attorney to undertake that
task there is going to be a lot of
various areas that that individual will
identify of needing help needing rules
perhaps rules that are outdated there's
a lot of offshoots of that project this
also doesn't mean that all hundred
thousand dollars has to be spent
but I think that amount is sufficient to
to Really spearhead that project and get
it underway
all right
thank you Mr chair I can't remember
Diane um was there an end date for this
that the task had to be completed by the
I'm just looking at the language of the
was it the end of 25 or 24
24 would be short I don't think it would
have been 24. September 30 2024. is what
the bill it was 24. oh it was 24. I
apologize
that's an interesting quote there's two
interesting questions here
yeah let me just
two issues one is
it's reopening the budget
uh
and we really want to do that
and the second one is
the process to to amend it if that's
what we want to do
I I've not done this before so I don't
say oh here's the three steps so what
what do we do do we get an amendment
Mr chairman
we could make the effective date the
next biennium
or we could say from funds not otherwise
appropriate if we know that the Senate
has put 297 million in Surplus education
trust fund like idiots but uh and and
the third thing I'm thinking of is
um
Anthony Daniel Antonio is retiring in
January
it would seem like the ideal guy
if he could be talked into taking this
on as a project
I mean he's been writing
what 30 years of education laws
just just a thought but those those are
the kind of things I would think of to
fund it either from the education trust
fund that should not be in Surplus or
money is not otherwise appropriated
and if if we don't see
money coming in from this budget this
term we make the effective date
next biennium
yeah thank you I um thank you Mr chair
I'm still concerned about the fact that
we are talking about the 100 000 being
amount uh you know good enough to
spearhead the project
I I would really like to have an idea of
I know that we cannot have an exact
estimate nobody will give you a quote
for this
but without at least some estimate of
how many years would it take and how
much would the overall cost be it's kind
of hard for me to justify you know
spending a hundred thousand to kind of
see how we're getting started and then
come back and see what we're really
looking at would it be possible to get a
moreover firm you know idea of what we
are looking at because it's kind of an
open-ended thing and I'm really
uncomfortable with open-ended spending
I don't think it's open-ended if you
start and you know with with a hundred
thousand dollars recognizing that the
very flexible and it will be fluid I do
think that
the project can
certainly
um I don't want to say be completed
because I'm speaking for someone who's
not going to be doing the work I'm not
doing the work we would hire someone to
do it
um but I do think a hundred thousand
dollars is an appropriate amount and I
don't say that lightly it is an
appropriate amount of money to undertake
this project does that mean that it will
be able to be completed under that
amount I certainly hope so and that
would be my expectation but I'm not here
to promise you that either I want to
recognize and I would be open with this
committee that that project there is a
lot to that education law book and there
are a lot of areas that I anticipate
they will that individual will find that
need to be identified and worked on so
I'm not here to tell you it's going to
just take four months and fifty thousand
dollars that would be an appropriate
testimony
um cool quick follow-up yeah but what
you are saying if I understand you
correctly is that you think it's
possible to complete it within a hundred
you just are not comfortable committing
to we do feel that this may be completed
this way you're just not sure
I appreciate that summary I believe that
however I will not put my reputation on
the line to say to you
we will not be back to ask for more
money because then you would look at me
and say remember last time you were here
you told us what's that you told us
exactly and I hate those moments so in
full transparency
um I just want to be clear I think it is
a significant undertaking I also think a
hundred thousand dollars would be well
worth it and could be completed within
that time frame and the department will
be very good stewards of the state's
money as the department always seeks to
be and we will make it clear in the
contract and clear on our oversight of
the individual who took on this project
this is the expectation thank you I'm
more concerned about the total cost in
the time frame the time frame is can be
flexible about the cost thank you I
really appreciate it thank you
thank you Mr chair Dan um this is really
sorely needed I mean as someone who had
to work with all those laws there are
laws that contradict laws and there are
a lot of things that are long overdue
with being fixed so I and I I think the
hundred thousand dollars is very
reasonable for one person to sit down
and go through this
um it makes a lot of sense
now the one concern I have is there are
kind of differences in some of the
legislation with the same intent now
when the person is going through all
these laws
how will they
they can't make a decision on what
should go and what should stay correct
so I'm assuming that they would have a
list of things that are questions that
the legislature has to answer
yeah so what looking at the language and
I agree with you
um the way we phrased it was to identify
okay areas that are duplicative identify
areas that are contrary to other
statutes and then to um you know
identify areas that can be Consolidated
because that's that's another big area
and then to report those findings and
recommendations for proposed legislation
to the commissioner
thank you no intend to change anything
it would have to be reviewed by us
though
well we would follow the typical
legislative process of seeking a sponsor
I'll tell you what I'll be in the second
thank you very much Mr chair I uh as you
okay there we go as you know I came here
to speak on 332 and it would have been
nice to speak on that but I I do con I
do agree that the legislation in general
is sort of like spaghetti code and
things go from one point to another and
it wouldn't it wouldn't be a bad idea to
have an attorney go through and sort of
identify the things and give you a side
by side so that the appropriate
committees can review this and decide
what changes to make well I what I
wanted to say here is is that had the
commissioner decided to do this rather
than hiring a spokesperson he would have
the money
and we would be using that because I
think this commissioner is very well
spoken very very a very good
communicator and that person that job is
probably not necessary to be in our
budget which is has remained thank you
very much
Okay so
what's the yes oh I have some notes from
our previous hearings and public
testimony that um I believe came from
the commissioner himself in regards to
page two
um
subsection three about the reporting
mechanism and my note says that he would
have preferred
um that the report be made
oh I'm sorry the Roman numeral three
it's actually the supervisory authority
over the attorney
it sounds like
um the commissioner would have preferred
that both the Department of Education
and a con to be in charge with in
consultation with the AG's office and I
have a note here that there was an
amendment that they had proposed to come
but I don't see that before us today
either and I just want to make sure you
know that we remember there was some
need from the Department itself to try
to modify what we're looking at today
and you know what I also have remaining
concerns about the scope but I just
wanted to make sure that
um that we remembered that that was
important testimony the commissioner
shared with us on that day
thank you
so moving forward if if the if the
committee so decides we can modify we
can recommend
amendments for full Finance
so the rec recommendation one is to
change the date
the time frame
as I as I hear the dialogue
and the second would be to
change the reporting Authority is that
I think it's the supervisory supervisory
Authority right now it's just under the
department itself but I think they
wanted to share that in consultation
with the attorney general's office
okay
all right
and
the third one is
out of we're going to have to change the
funding and make it as a not otherwise
allocated or whatever in order or to
take it out of the department out of the
the way the bills was drafted was it it
is an education trust fund charge okay
then let's leave it alone
with those
do we have a motion to move this to full
Finance
okay Joe do you have a second Mary
all those in favor
okay
well I I can draft the amendment and I
can send it to everybody after and uh
well that's what we'll vote on in full
committee so just to confirm we'll kick
all of the dates out 12 months right and
uh just add the commission or a designee
in consultation with the attorney
general shall have right okay
fund
okay
let me write a lot
521 Department of Education payment for
placement for uh episode of treatment
this I remember this instinctly is an
hb2 because we didn't know what an
um Joe most itl Mary second all is in
favor
okay
now we know what episode of treatment is
HB 529 receive an additional aid grant
for schools based on free and reduced
meal price
meals and fiscal capacity disparity
and this was handled in hb2 from Joe
mustas to itl Mary seconds all those in
favor
okay
uh 540
relative to adequate education grant
amounts for Education Services again
this is part of hb2
Joe moves to itl Mary moves the second
all is in favor
okay
establishing academic research and
Improvement performance data analyst in
the Department of Education
and this was
oh did I
sorry
541 relative to school building Aid and
Grant and make an appropriation
therefore
there's two of us
okay
so this one was in hb1
so uh 541 could be IPL Joe moves it
Merry seconds all those in favor
okay now we go to 542.
establish an academic research and
improve performance data analysts in the
Department of Education which did end up
oh I'm sorry I just I just looked down
and saw hp2 in parenthesis there
when the Department of Education was
before Senate Finance during its budget
work they didn't identify this position
as one of their prioritized needs so the
Senate made the pr uh the policy change
to the budget that passed over by
so
um move to Ito all right and the second
primary all those in favor of Ito
okay
all right relative to school building
we had it in hb1 does anybody want to
the same station that's just the same
ballpark the same Baltimore same topic
which have been kicking down the road
for a long time uh and I'm hoping that
what I'm trying to do now since I knew
that I thought this bill would not go
anywhere neither will this one I'm
trying to find the senator to sponsor
something or so that we can get some
money into the into the building a
program perhaps through the Surplus in
the education trust fund and the other
large budget surplus we had the money we
should spend it we've been ignoring our
school buildings far too long and so I'm
again I'm expressed by disappointment
that the finance committee didn't
address this in the budget we don't we
did only approved only three out of 17
applications and we all know that there
are many more schools across the state
that need repair and it's only getting
worse if we don't act thank you okay
but as far as
so just a CL just to clarify for
everybody this division had three School
building Aid bills that made
modifications and in most cases applied
are appropriated much more money than
the current statutory uh maximum of 50
million dollars the budget that ended up
passing was at the maximum statutory
level of 50 million dollars so just to
clarify that
so there's nothing to do on this bill
all right if if you wanted to do
anything with these bills you're
essentially would be increasing the
statutory cap that is in place now in
appropriating additional funds for
school building a program
I would make that Amendment
that we increase the statutory limit to
okay
the motion was to increase the statutory
limit of school building AIDS and 50
there was a motion uh from uh repetri to
it Elite which didn't get seconded and
then the piece came in so I just want to
make sure we're all aware of it but
there was no second correct but I just
wanted to make sure okay so right right
the motion is amendment to propose
amendment to increase the statutory
limit too yeah
70.
Mr chairman I've heard from some people
that some of the schools that really
don't need new buildings because they
have decreased enrollment saying oh we
could get 60 percent from the state
let's build
I think this this is bad because you
know and especially some of the
mismanagement that's happened like in
Concord where they give away buildings
that they should have sold for cash and
then ask us to pay for a new building
that's mismanagement and I don't think
it's right
but if we have this money sitting there
people are going to build things they
don't need because they think they're
going to get 60 paid for
I'm opposed
yeah Mr cheer
I respectfully reject your comments I do
not believe that school districts are
not using their money to the best use
possible for any minor amount of money
that they get for building Aid we have
Amy here today and I'm sure she can
attest
um Concord has the pre prerogative to
make decisions and they don't do it in
absence of anyone they've done a good
job building what they need to build for
the in the best interest of students but
I really and truly think that this is a
need that we've had we've been ignoring
our schools we had a 10-year moratorium
we need more money in building Aid we
tried during the budget process we were
unable to do it I think lifting the
amount the statutory maximum amount is a
simple step to go forward and I would
hope that everyone would support it
thank you
so raising the statutory to 70 million
means every
succeeding budget 70 million not just
this one
right yes
thank you Mr chair I would just like to
Echo or add that the Department of
Education has substantive procedures for
granting School building Aid and I think
that they've shown that they do a very
good job at that and I think I have
trust in the program that they have in
terms of awarding the the money it is
not done in a willy nilly willy-nilly is
that the phrase fashion that's been
suggested so I support their proposal
okay
yes sir thank you very much Mr chair uh
I want to point out that the average
building a grant is 38 that leaves uh
let me think 62 percent uh skin in the
game for the local community they have
to come up with the rest of that money
and you're not you're not qualified for
for the 60 unless you're unless your
community is dirt poor and they're
certainly not going to be willing to put
up the 40 if they don't have it plenty
of illustrations of this uh my good
friend Mr Weiler has a point of view but
I I have to say he's not looking at the
whole picture and we've seen a lot of
these sort of pictures around the state
with schools that are crumbling we've uh
We've bought a new building for the
education department which I certainly
don't want anyone working for the
education department sitting in a
building with asbestos and lead paint
but we have kids in school under those
okay there's a motion on the floor to
amend the bill
the statutory limit yes can I just
clarify one thing so I believe this
motion is to make no other changes
except for changing the 50 million to
70. and Amy Clark can back me up here
but I think you would want to make that
effective date July 1 2025 I feel like
this biennium has already closed off so
I don't know if if Amy wants to comment
on the timing of making such a change uh
mid-mid cycle
is that is that correct
okay so I'd say if this motion should
also include an effective date of uh
July 1 2025. okay
all right
any other further comment
five so the amendment fails I could have
a moment
so now for the
Bill itself
lost my place
recommend itl
second
no oh yes okay we are discussing HP
fiber okay okay great I just looked and
I saw a school building Aid Grant I went
to the wrong build
my apologies
546 relative to the school building 8
program still itl still a second okay
there's five of five okay
and those opposed
so five to four it is itl
okay
560. established a contact personal
notification program to assist law
enforcement Personnel who have contact
with a person with mental or physical
disabilities and making Appropriations
therefore
program was funded included in budget
hb2 Thank You itl by Joe
looking by Mary okay all all those in
favor of Ito
all right
relative to State participation in
Medicaid direct certification program
we passed this and it got taken out in
the Senate is that that's correct the
senate had a different approach for
fiscal 26 and Beyond when it came to
targeting aid for free and reduced lunch
students so they took out the Medicaid
direct cert and passed an enhanced
extraordinary needs Grant starting in
fiscal 26 instead the department is here
if there's any follow-ups but my
understanding is the USDA did not even
open up an application period for 23 so
had that bill passed I don't think the
department could have pursued a direct
start application this year anyways and
um thank you I'm I'm Brody deshais I
represent New Hampshire hunger Solutions
and we've been strong advocates for
passing this legislation so I just want
to First say the fed's pilot program is
still open states can still join the
pilot program for Medicaid direct
certification to my understanding if the
department wants to clarify as if I
missed if we missed something from Nam
stronger Solutions in our end a federal
policy that changed that could be the
case but usually we're watching Pretty
closely so essentially what how spill
601 would do would it would require the
Department of Education to opt into the
federal
um into the federal pilot program and
what that would do is it would make it
so then the state automatically
certifies students who partake in
Medicaid
um
to get free and reduced meals similar to
what we already do for snaps so families
up or taking the snap program are
automatically certified for free
introduced meals so this would capture
another 10 000 students that aren't
accounted for
um in the state of New Hampshire the
Senate's big issue with the bill wasn't
the intent and it wasn't the cost to the
department it was the fact that it
affected the um the adequacy aid
provided to school districts because you
have more students that will become
enrolled in free introduced lunch about
10 000 more students namschanger
Solutions has kind of held the position
that not only is this a bill related to
feeding students an increasing number of
students who are partaking in free and
reduced meals it's also a bill that
helps communities recapture state aid
that frankly they have a right to
property taxpayers are affected when
people don't fill out these applications
and you have tens of millions of dollars
left on the table because you have some
families that aren't filling out the
applications for a myriad of reasons but
ultimately it's property taxpayers and
school districts that miss out on these
funds and the students have partaken for
introduced meals tend to have more needs
that must be provided by the school
district so it's kind of um we're kind
of dealing with two issues here one is a
school funding issue and another one is
an issue of feeding students
so but we're strategically in going at
this is going in a different direction
than the Senate wants to go
as a larger question
is it
um could you clarify your question
representative we passed this for all
the reasons you just said and the Senate
took it out for a whole bunch of reasons
they have
are there reasonably going to change if
we we introduce this
I'm not entirely sure I can't speak to
what the Senate would decide or how
they're feeling in this upcoming year
but I can say you guys never got the
entire fiscal note
um because it wasn't finalized when you
guys went through it it was finalized
when the Senate went through it and when
you originally looked at the fiscal note
there wasn't there there wasn't um
there weren't estimates based on the
number of students that would be
enrolled and that would then be counted
in the free and reduced numbers for the
state advocacy formula
so at that time we thought the fiscal
note might be a lot smaller it ended up
becoming much larger
um so I guess your committee now has a
there's a lot more information out there
for you guys to make a another decision
on this bill of whether or not
you know you want to directly certified
you want you want the direct the
department to partake in the federal
government's pilot program directly
certify students who are on Medicaid and
free and reduced meals
and this had a cost didn't it
yeah Mary what I believe happened in the
Senate
they were for this until they changed
the Mickey correct me if I'm wrong they
changed the formula so that when the
they doubled the amount that would go
for f in our students and so when they
did the calculations for the number the
total number of direct certification
students it would have increased the
budget by 100 million dollars and at
that point in time they determined that
they didn't want to go forward with that
that being said I think we're doing a
disservice to our state and our children
we have I believe we have an obligation
to identify all the students in New
Hampshire that are eligible for a frame
reduced lunch we all know that they're
reluctant to fill out the forms
um
Joe you know your wife you did that job
um and there are children in New
Hampshire that are going hungry our
poorest of families are our young young
families and those are the children that
would qualify for this food uh food
um Surplus a question for you
um
when this law was established Medicaid
wasn't in place
um they had so that the
children that were on other
um
programs were automatically eligible
because it wasn't in the law now
Medicaid wasn't in the law at that time
that's why we are in this predicament
we're in right now is there any
opportunity in Congress in the Senate
the U.S to change that and include
Medicaid in that National piece of
legislation so we wouldn't have to do
this state by state thing that we we
have to do
well I think even for the direct
certification for snap the state still
had to partake in the program all right
they had to adopt it yeah okay so I mean
and that's and that's I mean that's you
know if if they had done Medicaid and
snap at the same time probably when this
state you know did this direct
certification for snap you know it would
have been more likely to have done it
for Medicaid too but you know the feds
to my understanding did snap first then
Medicaid so that's you know that's why
we've pushed for this legislation I want
to clarify though the fiscal note
at least to my understanding the fiscal
note that was on the Senate side showed
somewhere roughly between 60 and 70
million but we kind of really questioned
whether or not that was a totally
accurate fiscal note that's at least
from our perspective as an organization
we came much closer when we did
estimates based on the numbers so based
on the um the average daily membership
in Residence of students without and
then with Medicaid you know the number
of meals provided for free and reduced
meals we found it was about ten thousand
students across the state and that cost
to the state
specifically the education trust fund
would hover somewhere between we said
about 27 million and 30 million is some
of the estimates that we have internally
and I can provide the committee with
those estimates and be more than happy
to have you know a continued discussion
another thing we've talked about with
the Senate that we floated was doing a
you know a more limited pilot program
for the state so choosing communities
that have the highest percentage of snap
enrollment where we know that there's
food insecurity and maybe choosing the
top 10 or 15 towns and seeing how the
cost would impact the state and then
address this again in the next budget
cycle or pass this currently but have it
go into effect and during the next
budget cycle too so the committee could
you know reevaluate when they go over
hb2 next year
you can do things first as a clerk could
you repeat your name and your
organization because I didn't catch you
the first time uh Brody deschase would
you like me to spell that no I had that
I'm pleasantly surprised in the
organization uh New Hampshire hunger
Solutions see I focused on the name and
there was no room left in the short-term
memory for the organization and if I
could just ask a quick question
my understanding and I have to confess
that I didn't really follow exactly what
the Senate did here is that the senate
had the choice to allocate money this
way but instead they chose to put money
in a different funding formula with the
intent of targeting roughly the same
population or a population they felt
am I understanding this correctly or
what did you say about the final
processor so as as rep Heath mentioned
they increased the amount of money
provided per pupil in the adequacy
formula for students enrolled in free
and reduced meals now we're trying to
get more students this still ultimately
is trying to get more students enrolled
in for introduced meals so fiscal note
increase so this bill is trying to feed
more students but it has an impact on
the adequacy aid formula and has the
adequacy aid formula as we know was
really overhauled
um this session you know it's it changed
the price tag for this piece of
legislation understood thank you go
ahead
um I'd like to move OTL on this bill uh
to pass rather
um on this bill so that we can move
forward with the Medicaid direct
certification at the New Hampshire
Department of Education
um and it would not be with everything
that have to be would have to be done it
wouldn't even be effective probably once
they have the data until probably 2026
is what I understand but at least
we'd have an accurate number an accurate
number of the children in the state of
New Hampshire that are eligible that
should be eligible for reduced lunches
and will also have a more accurate
number for our adequacy figures because
we'll know exactly how many children fnr
because right now we only know the
numbers of those families who fill out
the paperwork we don't have any other
way of knowing because we don't have the
Medicaid direct certification so we're
missing hundreds and hundreds of
children and um
that's my rationale for moving this to
pass now does it would it need to be
amended
yeah it probably doesn't need to be
effective you probably could just pass
this without Amendment
um okay there's no there's no dates
locked in uh in the bill and it's
effective upon passage so does it have
money in it
so
at the at the end of the budget session
when the Senate was working with their
education funding changes as well as the
Medicaid direct certification decision
they did in fiscal 26 so the first two
years after the budget passed so it's
called 24 and 25 the extraordinary needs
Grant was maxed out at 8 500.
in fiscal 26 and each thereafter when
the house passed its budget that's when
Medicaid direct cert was going to kick
in rather than do that the Senate
increased the max grant for the
extraordinary needs Grant to eleven
thousand five hundred dollars so
layering Medicaid direct certification
on to the current Formula that's in
place in fiscal 27 let's say is the
first year that adequacy will be
impacted it'd be well over 100 million
dollars I would say in that in that one
year that the estimate that we had back
during the session was 109 million and
the fiscal 24
uh free and reduced lunch data that
ended up getting published a couple
weeks ago by the department was a little
bit higher than what we were using and
during the budget so I'd say that based
on doe and our estimates that's my
worries Mr chairman could ask a
clarification question about that
estimate sure does that include
um the cost the does that include the
increased so that fiscal note does that
include the increased revenue from the
federal government for the
reimbursements for free meals and
reduced price meals this this is just
State adequacy trust funding and that's
what that's what the committee needs to
remember is these meals are reimbursed
by the federal government so there is
revenues that will come in so while it
says 109 million there's a lot of money
that comes in from the federal
government to fund the program so it
looks like the state's spending 109
million but you don't see in the
background the federal government
kicking in a bunch of money for these
meals so that would be the new nutrition
reimbursement right we're talking about
just adequacy is a hundred I'm not that
we do have a separate estimate for the
nutrition match part of it and that's
not part of that number
yes
I object on two grounds excuse me
the parents could easily have filled out
the paperwork for the free and reduced
that's their choice some of them don't
want to do it for whatever reason
the second thing is this is used as a
measure of poverty
so more money goes to a school to spend
to help the children in poverty not to
feed them to help them
and so I have often said that the
department of Ed should set up a program
specifically for those children in
poverty to have either after school
homework help or something that they're
not getting at home that we could
certify in the Department of Education
ought to certify that a school district
is doing something separately for the
students that are in free and reduced
meal not just throw the money and even
the schools like and think in Manchester
there were five
five elementary schools one of them had
High far higher percentage of free and
reduced than the others but they didn't
get the extra money it just went through
the whole system that didn't help that
if this money is to be targeted for
poverty I want to see a program through
the department of Ed to help the
children in poverty to learn better
because those are the ones that don't
take books home don't do their homework
don't get any help at home so there
needs to be a program to do to deal with
that instead of just spending more money
and not even being able to have it
accountable that's what I've always
objected to in this whole thing every
other program English as a second
language here's the money here's the
hours you have to spend and so on and so
forth there's no accountability for this
money I don't like that spending money
with no accountability thank you
thank you Mr chair
I don't even know what to say to that
um respectfully
the schools in Manchester
do identify students who offering
reduced lunch and they do provide the
title one program their special
programming their special reading
programs there are any number of
specialized programs for those children
who are not acceding to the proficient
levels so I beg to differ Mr chair that
that in fact they are doing and
it is our responsibility as a state to
identify
free and reduce students in our state
I realize it's complicated because now
the change in the formula but I still
think we need to have accurate numbers
of children living in poverty ultimately
there will be more federal dollars
coming if we increase those numbers
we'll have more opportunities to apply
for more federal grants because we will
have more accurate information there are
innumerable reasons why we should move
forward with this I just think it's a
huge mistake not to be able to have the
most accurate data to send
our adequacy funds to our school
districts right now again I realize that
it is an option for parents that can
choose or not choose
but we need to know how many children
really are out there
it's not the children's fault that their
parents choose not to fill out those
forms
it's the children who go hungry and kids
can't learn if they haven't eaten I just
think we're being negligent by not
investing in a program that will help
number one to feed our children and
number two will give us better a better
count of the children that are in
poverty in the state of New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair
good thank you Mr chairman and regarding
the applications there's there's a
myriad of reasons why families don't
build the application sometimes they
don't feel comfortable providing
information to the government even
though we know that there's a lot of
privacy laws some families just will
never feel comfortable doing that
sometimes that has to do with the fact
that a family provides their students
with cold cold lunch from home and they
don't feel it's necessary to fill out
the form But ultimately
the community is the one that suffers
because it's less you're not actually
getting a proper measure as Rapides said
of how many students fall into these
categories and those students
disproportionately need special services
that the school districts are mandated
by the feds in the state to provide so
you know if you look at this outside of
just the fact that we're certifying
students to be fed a free school meal or
reduced price meal there's also the
reality that there's there's lots of
money that school districts based on how
the adequacy formula is written should
be getting but because the forms not
getting filled out for a vast number of
reasons the property taxpayers end up
putting the bill for a number of special
services that are mandated that must be
provided by the school district so
that's kind of why when I started I said
this is more than just a bill about
feeding students it's also a school
funding bill and a bill about whether or
not the property taxpayers are actually
that that the state is treating them
justly and ensuring that every student
that should be accounted for in the
education funding formula actually is
thank you and this is just a general
comment not a question it's um
it's a complicated topic right to
education funding God knows we spend so
much time going over it and digging into
huge amounts of detail just want to stay
that I'm really uncomfortable regardless
of how well intended the bill is
approving basically a unilateral change
in a budget that took so much
negotiation work to pass this would
really
be something that I could only consider
as part of an overall budget process
because this I can tell you right now
that if this would have been part of the
budget money would have been taken out
from somewhere else and I don't think
that it's responsible physically right
now regardless of how it well intended
how you know we are to now after the
budget was approved and passed to come
and change something in such a complex
formula I'm looking forward to
discussing this again you know in one
year plus when the news session starts
and we have a brand new budget but I
would only consider supporting the
legislation that would so drastically
affect the education formula as part of
an overall budget process where
everything is considered
um thank you I I definitely
if I may Mr chairman I definitely I can
understand that sentiment you know it's
we're not talking hundreds of thousands
we're talking tens of millions so I can
understand that but um there there are
ways to to move this bill forward where
we can help learn more about how this
program operates in this state and how
many students that we are missing by
making it a more limited program using
different metrics and data to measure
What towns um would participate in such
a program to get an idea of how many
students are we missing and how accurate
are whether it's estimates from
organizations like number New Hampshire
hunger Solutions or from doe to get a
better idea so there are ways to move
forward
um if the committee so chose that they
don't want to move forward with the bill
in its current iteration we're more than
happy to work with anyone on the
committee and with doe to help make
language that would be palatable that we
could get you know to help us learn and
understand better about how this program
would affect New Hampshire school
districts and communities and students
thank you Mr cheer thank you um Mickey
is it possible just to pass
the
um Medicaid certification
um to the Department of Ed so they begin
the process
my understanding this would not
impact this budget it would be
2026 before we even had the data that we
could use to um influence uh adequacy
budget so what I'm looking for is just
having the data made available so in
fact we know how many free and reduced
lunch students we have in the state by
doing the Medicaid direct certification
because the process is going to they
have to apply they have to conduct the
work with health and human services so
that in and of itself is going to take
probably another couple of years
but
yeah I'm not sure I would defer to
hunger Solutions in the department I
think once we apply I think we're in I
don't think we can apply Harvest
information and decide we don't want to
do it later I don't know if that's true
that was my understanding
um so I don't know if there is a way to
good afternoon Brian Eaton with
Department of Education Bureau School
Finance so that is correct you mentioned
representative Heath that there is a lag
time so that is very that's something we
brought up during the process I don't
remember who we talked about it with but
that is something to take into
consideration that I've been why it was
repealed why it was denied
um
because the impact was unknown I don't
know enough about the program to know if
we can enroll in the program and then
determine how many of our fnr students
are part of that Medicaid director I
don't know that we can follow up if
you'd like but that is something that if
it's possible we would definitely
potentially be interested in doing uh we
might have the bandwidth and on the back
end to make that differentiated Aid
almost within fnr to know of that F R
Who belongs to what group and what that
I do have a question
um I'm a freshman so I really don't know
the answer to this the suggestion from
Mr deschase earlier was uh you know we
could gather data or have a small pilot
or whatnot wouldn't that be a bill
that's sufficiently different from this
that it could just be introduced this
week as a standalone Bill and discuss
this session because I don't I I would
really not feel comfortable trying to
amend this based on a general
conversation and agreed to that
amendment I mean we that type of Bill to
me would be a new bill wouldn't be you
know part of this and the filing period
okay
we've sent 501 forward to this Senate a
601 forward to the Senate they have made
it a study committee
they have dealt with it in their books
if we do anything else with 601 they're
going to kill it because they've gonna
wait to find out what their study
committee does so it's not going to go
anywhere in the Senate
House Bill 2 did and I'm sorry a house
bill to when the Senate did pull this
language they did replace it with a
study committee for
um studying the free and reduced lunch
meal and how it impacts state aid
programs that committee's report is due
okay
yes
the chair can I just ask Mickey may know
or perhaps department of educational is
there a way to continue this
conversation
um further into the fall I fully support
the concept I mean it's who wouldn't
support the concept
um however there are so many unknowns
around the money that I really feel a
little uncomfortable uh going forward
full since it's clear that there are
going to be consequences and I think we
should have a better understanding of
what they are but I don't want this
conversation to end so is there a way to
move this forward
so Finance has until the full committee
has to exec its retained bills I Believe
by November 17th so that's when this
bill 601 needs to be exact
um the study committee as I mentioned
will be doing its work from now until 1
November uh so those are I guess the two
Avenues in on this topic
um so their recommendations would be up
before we have to vote
uh yeah yes
so Mr chair can we hold off on this
and it is just to clarify it's a it's a
House and Senate study committee it's
not just a senate study committee they
put it in-house Bill too but
um I'm not sure if appointments have
been made yet or if they've met but I
know yeah I don't think they have so but
I know they have a report date by one uh
one November
so the the
we continue to retain it yeah so no
action yes I guess okay so what what the
what division two would have to do at
that point is just have a future work
session on this build prior to the full
committee on so sometime between in
assuming that committee reports by one
November between one November and uh 17
November so we're putting it on the bus
okay so so the motion
there is no motion
you have no motion okay all right
all right
dodged a bullet on that one
yeah for now
uh 620 establishing a division of early
learning in the Department of Education
relative to pre-kindergarten pilot
program
I thought
could be we put we did this we retained
it
we didn't do anything with it we didn't
do anything with it
and it is not in the budget but it's one
so Mr chair yes maybe we have more
information so there was no fiscal note
but we've been sort of promised a fiscal
no do we have any further information on
what it would cost
the bill is also in the Senate and I'm
not sure what the action was in the
Senate
I know it was retained in the Senate but
I don't know if there was any action
within the budget
my understanding is the Department of
Education has launched some sort of an
effort
um relative to a like program is what we
had described in the pilot but in this
in 620 but I don't know anything further
than that
yes
a structure under the circumstances
since we already are going to have a
work session later to deal with the bill
we just took no action for since we seem
to still be waiting for information
should this also be a no action and wait
for more data and pursue that
information to make sure we can make an
informative is that the general
consensus we're going to meet again well
let's see if we can get some more
information if I may have I'll check
with Senator Whitley and see where the
bill is in the Senate and see what
they're doing and I'll come back with
more information thank you so that bill
is in Senate education re-referred so
they are working on that as well and I
will point out I think we've had
this bill waiting on information since
the winter so I'm not sure what we're
gonna what we're going to see correct
okay
638 relative to the extraordinary needs
Grant to schools
this was was handled in the budget
itl by Joe second by Mary follow us in
favor
so we will be meeting sometime after the
first of November
does anybody else have anything they'd
like to contribute to the committee at
this time
if not we're adjourned at two o'clock